one of the consequences of success is
that
you don't die
so who dies first well as soon as you
stress the system let's say we double
energy prices
well who's gonna what's the sacrifice
well old poor people
because they're more susceptible to say
death when the air conditioning when
they can't afford air conditioning when
they can afford heat
and so yeah but there's too many people
on the planet anyway so you know what
the hell we call a few
few whatever you know they're just poor
people and this is the thing that bugs
me so much it's like okay leftists
which side are you on here
it's like are you gonna are you gonna
sacrifice the poor
to your hypothetical future utopia
those people at the climate change
summit were serious what they would be
and and we could be very very specific
about this here's what you do if you're
a leftist who's
concerned about the environment and the
poor simultaneously
okay
you make power energy as cheap as
possible for everyone because there's no
difference between energy and wealth and
because rich people can't hoard energy
it's not a pareto problem right because
all the energy doesn't end up in the
hands of a few
so you try to build nuclear reactors
perhaps there's a bit of a problem
getting rid of the waste and there's a
lot of bureaucratic wrangling around
that it's not a solved problem entirely
but we don't have a better option than
nuclear in the long run
and so you make power as cheap as
possible so if you want to save the
climate you want to make power
everywhere in the world as cheap as
possible as fast as possible to make
people as rich as possible because the
richer they get the more they care about
the environment and that pattern is
clear in china and india which have
greened substantially in the last 20
years those two countries have greened
an area the size of the amazon in the
last 20 years and that's in addition by
the way just so everyone knows here's a
cool little fact you know that as carbon
dioxide levels rise
plants can grow in drier environments
drier environments semi-arid like
deserts like like
the sandbanks on oceans and lakes
stabilizing that as well and so because
the carbon dioxide levels have risen the
plants can close their pores the
breathing pores and so they don't
evaporate water as much and so an area
the size of alaska has greened in the
last couple of decades in addition to
what china and india have planted
and so
you know so what i worked for the the un
secretary general's committee on
sustainable development and to some
degree cop 26 is an attempt to bring the
corporate world in line with those
developmental goals and there was a
bunch of problems with the project
because there were 200 goals and that's
too many you have to prioritize them and
no one was willing to accept bjorn
lomberg and that's a different
conversation but what i learned because
i read about 200 books at that time on
the environment and sustainable
development and what i learned was
things are way better than anybody
thinks we have a glorious future in
front of us if we want to the best way
to save the planet is to make poor
people rich as fast as we possibly can
so that means we can have our cake and
eat it too and isn't that absolutely
lovely
and the biggest environmental issue
that's facing us isn't global warming
it's overfishing in the oceans as far as
i'm concerned because that's that we
could actually stop it's actually
extremely damaging and we know how to
stop it and trudeau to his credit by the
way has
uh produced a series of marine protected
areas along canada's coastline that
weren't there before now i don't know
how protected they are and how thorough
that legislation is but that's something
that that that he's done that that
actually counts as a credible
accomplishment in my estimation
so but
go ahead dave well so first off i you
know i've interviewed bjorn a couple
times but we his last book basically
illustrates i mean it's it's mostly
illustrations that lay out almost
everything you're saying here so i just
want people to know you're not making it
up we'll link to that interview so they
don't know so they can see it but yeah
go ahead okay so well look so so there's
these 200 development goals and
sustainable it's like okay well what is
sustainable mean and over what time
frame that's actually incredibly
complicated right because
time frame is a real problem do we mean
sustainable over 5000 years well why
should we care because god only knows
what the world's going to be like in 5
000 years just look at what computer
technology is doing we can't plan out
that far so that's probably too long 100
years well we're all dead then
and you might think well we should care
it's like yeah perhaps but how should we
care because we can't predict that far
out so the time frame is really crucial
and it's and then the fact that there
are 200 goals that's that's like zero
goals
like if you were trying to do 200 things
first of all at any moment you wouldn't
be able to do anything because at any
moment you can only do one thing and so
you have to prioritize and i asked
repeatedly when i was working on this
committee
why
aren't these goals prioritized and the
answer was well they all have separate
constituencies who are fighting for that
particular value and they get annoyed if
there's any like sequential approach
it's like okay well that just means we
do nothing because 200 goals is just
chaos
and then i found lomberg and
and so what lombard does is he he hires
teams of economists to assess the goals
in a given country or globally for that
matter
by cost benefit and you can you can
argue about that because there's
assumptions that you have to use that
are built into your analysis right
there's always a prior axioms and
prejudices and biases and so forth and
constraints but he does it with 10
different teams of economists so that's
kind of good and then he averages across
the whole set of the economists and then
you might say well it's an economic
analysis and that doesn't take anything
into everything into account it's like a
everything can't be taken into account
and b
do you have a better idea
and if not then well what good is your
criticism
like i haven't seen a better idea than
lomberg's idea but from anyone
so
is is part of the problem that people
because our institutions have in so many
ways failed us and i know you've
obviously talked about it and wrote
about it in your last book that we
shouldn't just needlessly want to burn
down these institutions but they've
they've sort of failed us to the point
that when they do these conferences like
these climate conferences i was
listening to obama's speech yesterday
and he's going on and on about how we're
going to have to sacrifice and all that
meanwhile he just yeah who's going to
have to sacrifice who's going to have to
sacrifice this fantasy million dollar
house he just bought a 15 million dollar
house on the water in martha's vineyard
i was just down in miami trust me
there's plenty of 40 million mansions
well there you go dave that's a
sacrifice because he didn't buy a 40
million dollar mansion
right so we should be thankful for him
as he flew but let's talk about
sacrifice yeah yeah okay so yeah let's
let the old people freeze in the dark
that's what's going to happen in europe
if we get a cold winter
so who's going to sacrifice here well i
can tell you the answer to that let's
play leftist here for a minute okay
so
there are hierarchies
and i think they're competence
hierarchies but they're corrupted by
power to some degree and how much is
worthy of investigation and we should
always clean them up i mean you just did
that in some sense when you said our
institutions are corrupt right and we
have to be very judicious which
institutions where are they corrupt how
are they corrupt at a level of detail
and
analyzed in a manner that allows us to
fix them instead of replace them
wholesale right so okay in any case
in a hierarchy
when there's stress
illness and death climb from the bottom
up
that's partly why you want to be nearer
the top in a hierarchy because it's
actually
psychophysiologically easier
well
obviously because otherwise why would
you strive for it i mean there are other
reasons you know maybe you want to do do
good for other people maybe you're
motivated by power maybe you're a
psychopath maybe you're acting
instrumentally there's lots of other
reasons but one of the consequences of
success is that
you don't die
so who dies first well as soon as you
stress the system let's say we double
energy prices
well who's going to what's the sacrifice
well old poor people
because they're more susceptible to say
death when the air conditioning when
they can't afford air conditioning when
they can't afford heat
and so yeah but there's too many people
on the planet anyway so you know what
the hell we call a few
few whatever you know they're just poor
people and this is the thing that bugs
me so much it's like okay leftists
which side are you on here
it's like are you gonna are you gonna
sacrifice the poor
to your hypothetical future utopia yeah
but they're all gonna die anyways
because the planet's gonna burn no it's
not the ipcc never said that
that so bjorn bjorn's modeled out you
know a reasonable amount of climate
change in meaning temperature increase
over the next hundred years he's taken
what's promoted as the scientific
consensus there is no consensus in
science that's not how science works
it's not a consensus enterprise but
nonetheless he's playing along with it
okay we'll take your figures
it's gonna produce somewhat of a
decrement in gb in in in global economic
growth but growth is about four percent
a year and so even if that declines a
chunk because of global warming it
everyone's still going to be like five
times as rich as they are now in a
hundred years if we don't screw things
up and so maybe they'll be four times as
rich
well that's a cost and fair enough you
know and if we can ameliorate it we
shouldn't probably we should probably
try not to change natural environments
any faster than we have to right because
of unexpected consequences it's a
reasonable argument but like here's
another thing this this
net zero
okay as soon as you hear someone say
anything like that zero you know they're
not thinking
it's like zero tolerances
to zero we shouldn't be trying to get
close yeah right exactly exactly well
and we don't have zero tolerance for
drugs
zero is the wrong number
zero pollution
well no
you know cows there's there's manure
from cows
people go to the bathroom
there's not zero pollution
so net zero
it's just it's an empty talking point to
put up a flag that you're on the right
side it's not differentiated careful
thoughtful thorough detail-oriented
thinking at the level that will actually
produce solutions and there's no
discussion about like what are we aiming
at here well how about
copious energy for everyone
as clean as possible but but in that
order copious energy for everyone lowest
possible price resilient stable systems
and to the credit to their credit the
democrats and their infrastructure bill
are building resilience goals in in
relationship to the power grid and
that's necessary because we should be
stress testing those systems constantly
but if you're on the left and you care
about poor people the only thing you
should really care about is cheap energy
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell